so let's switch gears and talk about
school the start of the school year at
ccsd it's a new beginning for students
and for teachers it's exciting it's
overwhelming it's coming up though and
it can be expensive for everybody too
mary jane villasa joining us live now at
the clark county school district center
with how teachers are preparing for this
new academic school year mary jane good
morning
john heather good morning to you i spoke
with one kindergarten teacher who tells
me her heart truly lies in the classroom
as she's celebrating 10 years of being a
teacher elementary school teacher
kristen nigro says preparation takes a
lot of planning during school break not
only is she budgeting for school
supplies but she's buying classroom
decorations reviewing curriculum and
thinking of all the fun to look forward
to this school year nigro says not only
is she looking forward to getting back
into the classroom but she's looking
forward to building a stronger
connection with her students
i've had an opportunity to take
a plethora of professional
and it's really helped mold me
into the educator i am today especially
the life experiences that's a huge one
because not every school year is the
same you know you go in and you think
like oh i can do this it's like riding a
bicycle but you just get all these other
crazy things thrown at you where it's
like the bicycle's on fire
and you're just trying to navigate the
best you can
niko tells me she's also excited to have
a sense of school normalcy she knows
that coveted exposure during school is
also a concern but it's nice to have
kids back into the classroom full time
and again of course school safety is
always another big concern too she tells
me teachers and school staff are always
up to date when it comes to reviewing
those safety procedures reporting live
mary jane valeza live local now